I get from here to there how did you
become a doctor studying practice your
Spence
tommy's YK caelius rejects the ancient
ones teachings he doesn't he sees learn
everything he could but he rejects her
philosophy of being the only one who's
allowed to be as powerful as that tell
me a little bit about shooting in Hong
Kong shooting in Hong Kong was in London
we built I didn't but they built an
entire Hong Kong streets with little
alleyways as well it was complete man it
was fantastic I had death
you gotta protect all this world
Marvel movie I'm playing a superhero did
you have that kind of moment on the self
nothing maybe the big fight with the
strange and the cape again when he gets
the cape that was also my sweet or a
moment of like this is mad we're flying
around
we're not 15 years old we're doing this
from the perspective of being on set
what's it like to actually be flying and
levitating it's fantastic it's it's a
tricky thing you have to coordinate with
your stunt guys and the guys controlling
the wires and it's a piece of music you
have to dance together they feel if they
do it literally I do the little too
early it doesn't work and does he see
strange as a worthy adversary you think
or more of just a blind follower what in
the better beginning he doesn't see him
as anything is quite surprised that he's
a common Tosh she's dressed like one
there's never heard of him and obviously
you can't be as powerful as me because I
always that point of master so he's just
a little speck way if you could take an
artifact with you and have it work in
real life as it does in the film sling
ring cloak of levitation I about moto I
mean if she can go from A to B and and
you know skip all LA traffic like that
that would be fantastic with the sling
but flying kind of I mean flying must be
fun I'll take the Cape and if I took the
Cape he wouldn't have it and then this
story would have ended differently